honestly I feel like it just keeps
getting better and better so you know
hopefully the honeymoon stage last
forever Marcus Jordan might be
happen but
it's backing their relationship after
basketball legend Michael Jordan spoke
out against his son's romance with the
Real Housewives of Miami star also I
feel like the world is trying to break
us up according to TMZ the sports icon
was leaving dinner in Paris on Sunday
when reporters asked him to share
whether he approves of his 32 year old
son dating the 47 year old TV
personality to which he abruptly replied
no now this seems to contradict with
what Marcus told us recently when
discussing his dad's feelings towards
the new relationship you know I think
there was a little bit of shock value at
first of course but my dad you know he
he tells me all the time look you're an
adult you know you can make your own
decision for your own thing and so you
know I just feel like he wants to see me
happy okay all very interesting now in
case you didn't know lars's ex-husband
Nichols former Chicago Bulls teammate
Scottie Pippen which may explain the
apparent beef but Larsa also addressed
this Dynamic while speaking with ET
Canada and I I feel I feel like a lot of
people don't know this but like when I
when or my ex and his dad played
together I was in college it was my
senior year in college right so it
wasn't like they only played together I
was only there for one year it wasn't
like I was there for the whole you know
Dynasty I wasn't part of all that